so let's move this story ahead and let's
bring in donald trump jr executive vice
president
of the trump organization author of
liberal privilege jill biden the
democrats
defense of the indefensible so majorcas
who's got the job for about seven days
down
good to see you again says quote in a
long
sound bite here says it takes time to
build out the depths of cruelty that the
administration before us
established what we are seeing now at
the border is the immediate results of
the dismantlement
of the system and the time that it takes
to rebuild it virtually from scratch
really i think since they took over the
whole
border is blowing up
without question uh brian it's
absolutely insane
they create a policy that says if you
come here
we're going to give you free health care
we're going to do this we have an open
border policy
that's creating a demand that's creating
a
flood of people coming in that's why
their systems are overwhelmed
because they're telling them to come
here and if you do
we will take care of you for life donald
trump and his administration
they built a wall illegal crossings were
going down
rapidly drug trafficking and human
trafficking
were cut into a fraction of what they
used to be by these asinine policies
of bad people using children using women
to get into america to do not so great
things in many cases
this is absolute insanity and again if
we had an honest media
if they didn't suffer or be able to get
away with liberal privilege
we'd be talking about the reality it's a
supply and demand issue when you give
them
everything they could possibly want they
are going to come and that's going to
create the crisis
and don speaking of liberal privilege
that's the title of your
new york times bestseller you i
understand would like to write
uh you know some sort of a new chapter
and you would title it i told yourself
explain
well a hundred percent i mean in the
first 30 days
alone i mean and if you include 35 days
because i said they'd be bombing the
middle east within a few minutes to be
able to satisfy the military industrial
complex
and the dc bureaucrats that want to sit
on the board of raytheon that's why
raytheon's getting 2 billion dollars
in the quote unquote stimulus package
i'm not sure what that does for covid
relief
but we will be sending more bombs into
the middle east undoubtedly
the reality is this everyone knew what
this radical administration
would do but no one would say it the
media went to great lengths to try to
cover
joe biden's radicalism the radicalism of
the people within his agenda said no no
he's not going to end fracking
he's not going to do that guys yeah he
is he said it a hundred times
i literally picked each and every one of
these things whether it's
energy great no problem with russia
having a pipeline that's fine but an
american pipeline
to make our gas prices cheaper to create
jobs we can't possibly have that right
same thing with immigration
amnesty free health care free education
sure that's not going to create a sway
towards the border that's not going to
draw people from all over the world to
try to get into the country illegally
so you the american taxpayer can have
the privilege of paying not just for
yourself
and your children but for them you can
flood those systems
you can get much less benefit from all
of it so the reality is this guys i
called all of these things last summer
in liberal privilege
now they try to suppress that i actually
had to create my own website
just don jr.com to sell it because
you've seen what they've done to
conservative publishers
and authors with cancel culture so you
know for those who want to get it go to
don jr.com you'll see that
this information was right there but no
one in media
no reporters or journalists were ever
willing to
actually look at the facts and report
them because they knew
that that would hurt joe biden and their
ultimate goal of putting
democrats in charge you were just
criticized this week for
the picture with the guns behind you and
so are some other lawmakers and
there's this cancel culture trying to
cancel dr seuss now
how far are they going to take this uh
okay there's no place that they won't go
uh ainsley there's no place they won't
go
this week alone they canceled mr potato
head
uh you know this week alone they
canceled the muppets
uh you know they're they're canceling dr
seuss from reading programs i mean these
are books
i literally know the cat in the hat by
heart without the book there because i
read it so many times
to my children these things are not
racist you have oreo cookie
chiming in on trans rights i mean what
is going on i have no idea it's
absolutely insane we've lost our minds
and we're encouraging it you know by
allowing it you saw
you know the world mob goes after cpac
because the stage apparently had nazi
symbolism because these guys are so
obsessed with
trying to create any link to that and it
looked like hyatt was doing a good job
but in 24 hours they too came
to the woke mob don thanks so much
appreciate it uh there's so much to go
over we'll talk to you again
thank you thanks guys pick up liberal
privilege now on our paperback